I hope everyone is staying dry. Um
I'm not.
So, as I mentioned last time, the Marine
project had a
which was running and it finished and it
actually matched the the forecast. So,
remember we were running these each of
these curves is
essentially a iso flops curve, which is
a bunch of smaller model runs
and you try to find the computer optimal
point. You fit a scaling law and this
was the point where
we predicted the loss and we ran the
loss the model and it got lost within
0.05. So, I thought that was pretty cool
and if you extrapolate out to GPT-5
level performance, this is the loss you
get. Of course, your mileage might
vary depending on how these scaling laws
are.
Okay, just wanted to share share that
news.
Um so, last lecture
I gave an overview of the entire class
and we are talking about tokenization,
which is going to be on the first
assignment. Um today I want to talk
about um
um resource accounting, which is going
to be more on the systems side of
things.
Um so,
uh to recall,
the the main thing we're trying to do is
um train the best model we can given a
finite set of resources, which could be
a compute, memory, sometimes data, but
that's not really going to be a limiting
factor for us in this class.
And our goal is to simply to maximize
the computational efficiency of our
training.
So, before you can optimize the
computational efficiency, we need to
understand the efficiency of a given
computation and for that we need to
understand the compute and memory
characteristics.
Um just to give you a taste of the type
of questions you will hopefully be able
to answer by the end of the class.
Um so, here's a question. How long would
it take to train a 70 billion parameter
model on 15 trillion tokens on
Actually, this should be H100 cell.
Um
So, how do you answer that? Well,
there's a formula which we'll talk about
how you can get the number of flops to
be be six times the number of parameters
times the number of tokens. Um we can
look up the spec sheet to see how fast
the H100 is.
Um we have this thing which called MFU,
which we'll talk about 0.5.
Um then you can estimate the number of
flops
um that you need
that you the hardware gives you per day
um and then you can compute the number
of days. So, the number of days is 143.
Okay.
Um here's another question. What's the
largest model you can train on H1 eight
H100s using Adam W?
Um so,
uh you can look at Well,
H100s have 80 GB of HBM
memory.
Um the number of bytes a per parameter,
which is 2 + 2 + 4 + 4.
We'll explain where that comes from.
And then the number of parameters is um
that you can get is going to be about 53
billion. So, there's some caveats here
that we don't count the activations,
which depends on the batch length and
batch size and the sequence length.
So, this is all very rough back of the
envelope calculations, but hopefully by
the end of this class you'll understand
where these come from and the point is
not to
precisely calculate every single thing,
but just get the rough shape of things.
Um okay. So, last time I talked about
knowledge and what you can take away
from this class.
Um mechanics, which are how things work.
So, today that will be pretty
straightforward. The mechanics are just
how PyTorch work, how tensors work. It
should be fairly
There's no magic here.
Um the mindset I want you to impart on
you is that resource accounting is going
to be very crucial and while everyone to
get in habit whenever you write you
know, a piece of line of code, think
about you know, the performance
characteristics.
And then finally, intuitions. Here we're
just going to get a sense of the the
resources, how they're spent. There's
going to be no ML magic today. I'll
leave that to Tatsu for the next
lecture.
Okay.
So, let's get into things. So, let's
start bottom up and start building up.
So,
what is at the bottom?
The the bottom are tensors. So, tensors
are the building block of storing
everything.
If you have parameters, gradients,
optimizer states, data, activation,
everything essentially is a tensor.
Um so, you know, for example, you can
take a look at the DeepSeek
3.2 model
and you see that the model itself is a
bunch of different tensors. Each tensor
has some shapes and also some precision,
which I'll talk about
later.
And
so, as as you know,
tensors subsume vectors, matrices
and
and can be generalize to any number of
entities.
Okay.
So, let's talk about how
much tensors take
to store.
Um
So, it depends on the the type of
tensor. So, in general, we're going to
be dealing with tensors that store
floating point, but tensors can also
store
you know, integers
and other types.
Um so, for floating point,
um
uh typically whenever you talk about
float, I think the standard people refer
to as float what is called float 32.
Um so, a float 32, if you break it down,
has 32 bits. One of the bits is a sign,
eight of bits are the exponent, which
gives you dynamic range and
the rest is the the mantissa or the
fraction, which gives you kind of
you know, variation.
Okay, this is also known as FP32
or
you know, single precision.
Um so, and the term single precision
comes from the fact that back in the day
when you're doing scientific computing,
float 32 was sort of like a baseline. It
was just like you expect if you someone
gave you a float, you would kind of
expect it to be at least single
precision and if you want
um
more precision, then you can get double
precision as that's you know, float 64.
But in deep learning, we're kind of
going the other way because even 32 is a
lot and the types of computations that
we want to do don't demand the high
precision that some kind of numeric
simulations do.
Um okay. So, before we get to other
types, let's just look at a float 32.
Okay, so let's construct a 4 by 8
matrix.
By default, the type of a tensor you
create is float 32. So, if you want
something else, you should declare it.
Um and the memory usage is just the
number of elements times the element
size here, which is 4 bytes
for a 32-bit
number
and that's going to be 128 bytes.
Okay.
Um
just to give you kind of perspective.
So, in GP3, which is a fairly old model,
one of the matrix in the feed forward
layer is
um
about
you know, 2.3 GB.
Okay, so these tensors can be you know,
get quite big and this is by far even
the biggest one that one can imagine.
Okay, so
So, since we're interested in
efficiency,
we want to generally reduce the amount
of storage um
and and we'll see that as you reduce the
precision, um you actually save my
memory and you also save time because
operating on uh
you know,
16 bits is going to be faster.
Um let's say
twice as fast, but not always it sort of
depends, but um
and and then memory
by reducing memory, we'll see later that
actually reducing memory can save time
as well,
which is maybe less obvious, but it will
hopefully become clear.
So, the the obvious thing is you say,
okay, let's take away half the bits. Now
you have float 16.
So, float 16 says you have a sign, you
have only five bits of exponent and then
the rest is the the mantissa.
Um so,
fine, fifth float 16 is is is good,
except for
you know, its dynamic range is
kind of poor. Right? So, even if you
have, let's say, try to construct a 1E
minus 8 tensor, then that is actually
just zero.
So, you can't really represent very big
numbers and you can't represent very
small numbers.
Um and the reason is that this exponent
is you know, it's only
you know,
you know, five bits of of exponent from
compared to eight.
So,
if you train with FP16, which people did
back back in the you know, day,
you will get instability. You will you
get underflow, you get overflow, you'll
get NaNs. It's it was it's pretty
challenging.
So, then
so, BFloat16
was invented. So this was developed in
actually 2018 to address this issue.
And the observation was that well, let's
not compromise on
the number of bits. It's it's it's the
number of bits is going to be the same
as FP16, but we're going to shift some
of the bits from the mantissa to the
exponent.
So that means it has more dynamic range
than float you know uh
16.
Um
and it actually has the same dynamic
range as float 32.
But of course the the resolution is
worse because there's no free lunch
here.
But it turns out that in a lot of deep
learning applications,
this is well worth the trade-off. You
want the dynamic range to not overflow
and underflow and because things are
kind of sloppy and stochastic anyway,
you don't need that much resolution.
Okay?
So
let me actually skip over this this
part.
So
So okay, so to summarize what are the
what are the implications for training?
So you can absolutely train with float
32.
And if you're training a small model,
you probably just and you don't want to
worry about it just you know float 32 is
fine. But it requires four bytes of
um
uh of sorry, four bytes of memory per
you know float. And that can take up a
lot of memory. Um and if you
train with float 16 then that's going to
be too risky. So float 30 16 a BF 16 is
sort of a sweet spot. Um even BF16 can
be kind of risky as well maybe see in a
little bit.
Um one thing that people have has become
kind of common practice is to use mixed
precision training.
Um and
actually let me
I think these
Okay, let me compile this again.
I think these are stale. So mixed
precision training is uh where some of
the computations use
some precision and for some other
computations use other precision. So in
general as a general rule,
BF
you know 16 is
what you would use for parameters
activations and and gradients. And for
optimizer states, you would use FP32.
We'll discuss a little bit more of that
about that later.
And to do invoke mixed precision
training, so PyTorch has a AMP library.
We're not going to talk too much about
this, but you basically um
wrap your code and
PyTorch has the library takes care of it
automatically for you in the sense that
it tries to cast things into
BF16 when it's safe. So for example,
matmuls are generally safe, but if you
try to do
exponentiation, then it will try to
leave things as
FP32.
Okay, so we could do BF16 I think is
probably where this class will end. But
if you're feeling very adventurous, you
can go farther. So FP8 this was
introduced four years ago.
Um it actually has been you know
standardized. So if you look at FP8,
there's actually two versions
because depending on if you need more
dynamic range or more resolution. Um and
um there's there's you know two versions
of them.
Um and so we're not going to talk about
that, but you know Nvidia has some you
know the transformer engine supports
FP8. And well most recently, you can
actually go down to FP4. So last year
Nvidia developed NVFP4 and there's only
four bits per value. So if you just to
so we're on the same page, four bits is
not a lot. Like I can write all the
values down on a single line here
between minus six and and six. Um so
that's not very much precision. Now
there's a little bit of a cheat here,
right? Because if you just naively only
use these values,
um you're you're not going to be able to
train
very very well. So what actually this
means is that you every value
you can have this four bits of freedom.
But there are blocks and each block can
be scaled up and down accordingly. So
you can actually represent more values,
but you can't
represent the full
dynamic range for every single value.
And there was a model released
actually this year, the NeMo-3 Super
which was trained in FP4 which I think
is a pretty pretty cool.
Okay. So some of this you it's just good
to know and some of this you can't even
even touch. It's not like you create a
tensor and you call call it FP
you know it FP4. A lot of this is done
under the hood by Nvidia's
you know software stack.
Okay, this was a bit of a kind of a long
digression, but it's it's maybe helpful
to appreciate that
the intricacies of you know precision
here.
Okay, any questions before I move on?
Yeah. Sorry
there's a question like when you have a
block you're scaling all those same
values like like you have a tensor by
that block something like that.
The ratios of all of them will still be
in FP4.
Yeah, so the question is just like
scaling with the maximum value is to
have more specificity.
Yeah, so the question is okay, just to
explain the block a bit more. So you
have let's say a block. Within that
block you can vary
up
within the four bits. And in addition,
all those values can be scaled up and
down according to how many of your bits
your scaling factor is. So if you look
at an individual value,
you actually get more than four bits of
dynamic range, but it's just like you
can't have this value be way over here
and the next neighboring value way down
Okay, so
uh one question about like
what about like one bit?
Uh
couldn't BF16 be pushed to a bit one bit
and all of that? Yeah, so there's a
problem with training obviously.
Right, right. So so maybe this is a good
point. So the question is about one bit
because you can't really go lower than
that.
So
there's a difference between training
and inference. So a lot of the low bit
stuff
if we talk about quan- I think we'll
talk about quantization later. Is that
you train a model at
on and you know maybe even BF16 and then
you quantize into like let's say one or
two bits. Um and that is much easier
than training a one bit
language model which I don't think
anyone has
you know done. Maybe it's possible, but
I don't think anyone has trained
anything credible there.
Okay.
Let us go on then. So we talked about
tensors and the memory calculus is
pretty simple just the number of
elements times however much memory each
element takes up.
Um so
you know by default the tensors you
create in PyTorch are going to be on CPU
and
um and of course you have to if you want
things to go fast, you want to move them
to GPU. And actually so there's a bit of
a I have a slight issue with the slides
with that. They were executed on my
laptop which means that I don't have
GPU. So some of the code I'll just show
but not um
execute. Um
so
to okay, let's see.
This is maybe not that the interesting,
but I think everyone knows how to move
um
tensors to GPU. But just remember to do
that otherwise you won't get your
speed ups.
Okay, so we talked about memory of
tensors which is very straightforward.
Now let's talk about computing with
tensors.
So before talking about flops accounting
for um
the the tensor operations,
let's take a little bit of a digression
to talk about einsums. So how many of
you have familiar used einsums before?
Okay, so like maybe two thirds. Okay,
good. So um
the motivation behind einsums for those
of you who might not be indoctrinated is
it's very easy to mess up or I I find it
very confusing to
look at code such as this and you you
have X and Y and then you have like
transpose minus two and minus one and
you're trying to figure out like what
what minus two and minus one is. Um
And so this is kind of maybe
the motivation
for um
you know using variable and names rather
than indices.
So einsums is a library for manipulating
you know tensors where the dimensions
are named. And this is inspired by
Einstein summation notation. There's a
nice tutorial which you can go through.
I'm just going to cover some of the you
know basics.
Um
So basically the way to think about
einsum is a generalized matrix
multiplication with
you know good bookkeeping. So here's an
example. So I have
um
a matrix 3 by 4. I have a 4 by 3 matrix
and if I do the matmul,
this is you know this is actually you
know pretty nice. It's pretty easy to
understand.
Uh in einsums, basically you say
X has two dimensions, the row and the
column which I'm going to name seq1 and
hidden. I'm going to have Y that's a
matrix which has also rows and columns,
which I'm going to name um
hidden and seek two. And um I'm going to
produce um a um tensor or here a matrix
where um the dimensions are indexed by
seek one and seek two. And anything that
is not mentioned here, the hidden, uh
gets summed out.
Okay? So, the way this works is I'm
going to sum over enumerate over all
possible values of all the variables uh
that
occur here, which are seek ones, hidden,
and seek two.
And I'm going to basically um index into
X, index into Y, multiply them, and dump
them accumulate them into um the result
Z uh sub seek one seek two.
Okay?
All right. So, you say this is
Come on, this is much easier than this,
right? Um so,
Okay, let's try a more complicated
example. So, um here's the example I
showed
you know, before. Now we have a a
tensor. It's 2 by 3 by 4 and another
tensor 2 by 3 by 4. And if I were doing
things um kind of the old way, basically
I am what I'm doing is uh transposing
these last two and then um
because uh at implicitly sort of batches
the the dimensions that are not the the
matmul dimensions, um
then you get the answer. Okay? So, you
have to kind of reason about this a bit.
Einops makes this very uh clear. It says
there's a batch dimension, there's seek
one uh hidden, seek two hidden, and I'm
just going to produce batch uh seek one
seek two.
Okay?
And notice that there's no transpose
because I just you know, in some sense
I've done the transpose by the naming.
If I had hidden um and seek two, then it
would be a no transpose. I always get
confused by transposes and the fact I
don't have to think about transposing
makes me happy.
Okay.
So, um if you want to get fancy, uh you
you can say, well, batch um I'm just
going to replace with dot dot dot. And
this means that if I had, let's say, uh
you know, uh a you know, rank 10 tensor
with, you know, eight different uh you
know, batching dimensions, I can just
write dot dot dot without enumerating
all of them.
Uh and this comes up in um you know,
language modeling because you might have
a batch dimension, you might have a
sequence dimension, you might have a
head dimension, and you're trying to do
like this matrix operation for all of
them. And you might not want to um have
to just, you know, worry about this.
Um and the nice thing is that you can
write modular code where you can write
this dot dot dot uh without worrying
about, you know, the even the shape of
the tensor that, you know, comes in.
Okay?
All right. So, that's uh ein sum, uh
which is in the einops uh library.
Um there's a reduce.
So, this is a generalization of sum,
mean, um max, and min.
So, um for example, if you have, let's
say, uh this this tensor,
and you want to sum
um according to dimension of dim minus
one,
okay, which means sum along the the last
uh dimension here.
Um so, again, I don't like the uh this
this notation, but what you can do is
called reduce.
And basically what you say is that
there's some batching dimensions. In
this case, it would be um this first
these first two. And then there's some,
you know, hidden uh dimension, which
doesn't appear on the right side, which
means that it gets summed.
And here I put sum, which means that the
aggregation reduction operation is sum,
but you can replace it with uh mean or
max or min.
Yeah. Is there some speed up to this?
Is there some speed up to this? This
basically reduces to the same type of
primitive operations. You can think
about it as just uh sugar.
So, it should be the same.
Um okay. So, the final thing I'll talk
about is rearrange. So, this is I think
a pretty powerful tool. Um
I think it will come up in the
assignment once. Um
So, sometimes you have a dimension that
actually represents um you know, two
dimensions, and you want to operate on
one of them. And the reason this happens
is that sometimes you have a matrix and
you flatten it.
Um okay. And then you want to maybe
unflatten and flatten. So, this is the
way that works here.
Um
So, imagine I have a um a matrix 3 by 8,
but where the um
this
uh the the this dimension eight actually
represents like a 2 by 4 um matrix. So,
um
I want to multiply that 2 by 4 matrix by
this 4 by 4 matrix.
So, what I'm going to do,
um actually, is to um call rearrange.
And what I am doing here is saying
um
Look, this is some number of batch uh
dimensions, which here just corresponds
to the first uh element here. And then
here I use parentheses to say that this
H actually represents the product of
heads and hidden one, um where I have to
obviously there's multiple ways to
decompose this. Could be 2 by 4, 4 by 2.
So, I said the number of heads is two,
which means that hidden one is four.
And then
I can um break that up into um you know,
two dimensions, heads and hidden.
Okay? So, uh this creates um this So,
before X uh looked like this, and now X
uh looks like, you know, this.
So, um cuz this might be a little bit
hard to see. Um
So, then you can perform your operation
transformation on uh W. And this is sort
of what we've seen before, where you
have um just a standard matmul, where um
there's on some number of batching
dimensions um for X here. And this is
hidden times um
hidden by hidden two.
Um and then once you've done that
transformation, you can rearrange it
back.
Um and this is straightforward. You
basically look at two dimensions, and
then you can group them into to one
dimension.
Okay?
Yeah.
Like if you take a two-dimensional thing
and shift it into one dimension, are
there two ways?
Like you could do it row major or column
major. Yeah. So, the question is that if
you have a one-dimensional thing and you
shift it into Sorry, you you have a
two-dimensional thing and you shift into
one dimensional thing, which way do you
uh do it? Well, the order you do it is
specified in the order uh here. Oh,
okay. Yeah.
Okay.
So, I I
Sometimes I find it takes a bit of time
to get it used to, but it's well worth
it because once you have einops, then
you just think in a sort of a different
way, and all the transposes and
reductions all of them it's just like um
uh it's becomes more fluid. Right? You
just have to think through these kind of
more um bespoke primitives.
All right. So,
Okay, we're going to use uh einops. Um
we'll see it a little bit later.
Um so, let Now let's go return back to
resource accounting question. So, I have
tensors. We've talked about how they
take memory. So, how much compute do do
they take? Okay? So, um the
thing we're going to use to measure
computation cost is the number of flops.
A flop is a floating point operation,
and it's going to we're going to assume
it's a basic operation like addition or
multiplication.
So, now there's other things that you
know, GPUs can do, but for the most part
we're just going to uh ignore them
because these are the the bread and
butter and are going to eat up most of
your um
time.
So, one thing that is a kind of a pet
peeve is that if I say the word flops,
it's actually ambiguous what I mean. Um
so, there's flops, which is saying the
number of floating point operations,
usually written flops with a lowercase
S. This is a measure amount of
computation done. And then there's
FLOPS, um
which is floating point operations per
second.
Um sometimes it's also very confusingly
written as FLOPS with uppercase S, which
but I'm going to always write /s to make
it clear that this is uh measuring the
speed of hardware.
So, if you go and see that uh H100s have
800 989
um
um you know, teraflops, it's the second.
And when I say that, you know, GPT-3
took, you know, a 3e25 or whatever it
is, uh flops, that's the the former.
Okay?
So, just to get that out of the way.
Um
so, just to give you an order of
magnitude, so the number of FLOPS when I
talk about 1e22
or 23 or 25, these are kind of referring
implicitly to amount of compute or the
scale of some of these models.
And uh so, if you look at H100s, um
um you know, if you look at this uh
glossy's uh
uh spec sheet, um actually, it's not on
this page. Okay, forget it. Um
there is a spec sheet and it'll
uh it'll tell you that for uh BF16,
the number of uh uh FLOPS/s
is um
uh 1979.
Um and then you go and you benchmark and
it's like, wait a minute, that's not
actually what I'm getting. And then you
go read the the, you know, the fine
print and there's a footnote that says
this is with uh sparsity, so sparse
matrix, and for dense it's uh you know,
over two. Okay? So, all you always have
to take these numbers divide by two. So,
that's why you see these uh divide by
two.
Um okay.
So,
so this allows us to um
you know, uh you know, just so our
intuition, so if you have eight H100, so
this one node uh for uh two weeks,
that's um
you know, H times the number of uh
seconds uh per in two weeks.
Um
actually, this is looks like it's one
week. Okay, fine. It's a one week uh
times uh the number of flops you get per
second. So, that's you know, about uh 5e
21.
Okay, so this is just kind of building
intuition for the number of flops that
certain types of hardware have and how
many flops, you know, certain types of
models uh require.
Okay, it's nothing fancy, it's just math
and uh napkin math. Um
Okay, so so now let's do some more
something more mechanical. Um
So, you know, suppose you have uh a a
linear model. Um
it turns out that a lot of this calculus
is uh
of counting flops is actually going to
be at the core it's like linear matmuls.
So, this is actually not without too
much loss of generality. So, you have M
points, each point is D dimensional, and
um we're going to map
uh
each of these D dimensional vectors to
uh a K dimensional output. Okay? So, um
so B is going to be the number of uh
points, D is the number of dimension
input dimensions, and K is the number of
output dimensions.
Okay, so we're let's construct uh some
uh an X, which is the data matrix B by
D, the weight matrix is D by K, and we
do a the matmul.
Um
the question is, you know, how many
flops uh that is.
And uh it turns out that this is going
to be two times
um
the
uh basically the product of all the the
three dimensions.
And the way to see that is that um we
have one, you know, multiplication
for each uh you know, triple,
and then also one addition.
Okay?
So, there's a minus one because if uh
you don't you have to actually add like,
you know, um
in this case uh D minus one times, but
let's ignore that.
Okay, I'll come back to this um if this
was a bit fast. Um I think there's a
there's another way to uh you know,
derive this.
So, what about the flops of other
operations? So, um element-wise
operations are just uh you know, the
size of the matrix. I think that's
fairly clear, so addition also requires
NM flops. Um so, in general, no other
operation you encounter is expensive as
matrix multiplication for large enough
matrices. So, in general, we're just
going to focus on what matmuls are doing
with the important caveat of when we
talk about memory. Yeah.
I would just just like this is for
interest, like there are some other
algorithms for doing matrix
multiplication. Is this only for, you
know, just doing it
normally?
So, the question is that there are other
algorithms for doing matrix
multiplication. You mean like sub cubic
uh cubic algorithms. Uh so, in general,
that's
the optimization the algorithms that
people are going to explore for much of
matrix multiplications are going to be
much more about how you co-design with
the systems rather than these more
asymptotic uh algorithms.
Yeah.
Yeah. Um we're considering addition and
multiplication in the same way. It's not
possible to do addition more efficiently
than multiplication.
Yeah, so I think the way uh the hardware
is built, the two are basically the, you
know, the same. But yeah, intuitively it
seems like addition I can do addition
faster than do multiplication, but um
the hardware the way hardware built is
built they're kind of the same.
Okay, so
you can think about this matmul as um
B is the number of data points,
um and DK is the number of parameters,
right? So, remember X is B by D and W is
D by K.
So, another way to think about this um
formula is that the number of flops uh
in order to do a forward pass of this
linear uh matrix is actually two times
the number of tokens or data points
times the number of parameters.
Okay?
So, this is a you know, it turns out
that this actually generalizes to
transformers, which if you remember the
six times N times D formula, we can kind
of see the shape of that uh you know,
forming.
Okay, so um
unfortunately, these calculations are
not going to be very meaningful because
I'm doing this on on on CPU, but I'll
just walk through the
uh the code here. So, um
so the what we've so far done is uh
measured flops. So, this is independent
of of hardware, it's just like the
number of calculations you need to do
for your model.
So, now the question is like how long
does it actually take on hardware?
So, one way to find out is you just time
it.
Okay? So, in this class, I think in uh a
few lectures we're going to talk more
about uh benchmarking, um but here's a
little preview.
So,
um in general,
um when you time, especially on on GPU,
you um have to call uh CUDA synchronize
to to make sure that because, you know,
the GPU is like kind of running
asynchronously, you want to make sure
that you have this kind of
synchronization point.
Um and then you perform the operation,
and after the
uh operation,
then you
uh you also have to have the
synchronization barrier. If you omit
this, you're going to find that wow,
your timings are really fast, and that's
because these this is a non-blocking
call, it just returns.
Um and often it's general good practice
to try this multiple times and take the
the average.
>> [clears throat]
>> Okay.
So,
so um the actual flops per second
is um
basically the number of flops you did
times the time that you recorded on your
hardware.
Right?
And um so, remember there's a also a
number number, which is the GPU has a
spec sheet.
Uh let's see if I can pull it up on this
link.
Um
I feel like maybe I have the wrong link.
I'll have to fix that after class.
Um
that's uh it gives you
um some number of flops, which was 989
um
teraflops.
And so, in general, the number of actual
flops per second is going to be
different from the promised uh flops per
second.
Okay?
Um and the
Okay, um oops.
Sorry.
And the uh the way to direct think about
the discrepancy is something called um
model flops utilization or MFU.
And the definition of uh MFU is the
actual flops per second divided by the
promised uh flops per second. And here
this is, you know, ignoring the the um
you know, the communication and other
overhead.
Okay? So, you basically take the actual
and divide by the promised.
So, in general,
um
you know, it's rare that you get more
than what's uh you know, uh
I mean, it's
yeah, you you just never get anything
more than what you were promised. Often
you get less, and in general, if you get
about MFU of uh 0.5 for modern models,
um you should be pretty happy with
yourself. Um if you have only just like
a straight-up matmul, you can get maybe
like, you know, potentially like 80 uh
0.8 um even. Uh but you you usually
can't get that high. And sometimes if
you're um have really,
you know, something's really wrong,
you'll get something like 0.1, which
means that you should do something.
Okay.
So, whenever you're you write your
model, you can calculate uh you now know
how to calculate MFU through a
combination of counting the number of
logical flops that you
uh your model is needs to, you know, do,
um and then looking at the wall clock
time and essentially dividing.
Yeah.
Was there a question over there? Oh.
Yeah, so is the promised What is the
promised flops number? That is um in the
spec sheet, it is
um
already divided by two
um of the 1989 number.
And then on top of that you only get
like 0.5 of that in in general,
depending on your um computation.
You're getting 50%
Yeah, so why are you getting only 50%
MFU?
Um actually, that's a good question.
I'll come back to that when we talk
about memory bottlenecks.
Okay, so to to summarize here,
um matrix multiplications dominate um
the
you know, generally the computations,
and that's sort of by, you know, design.
Um
so
um
and the number of flops per second
depends on the hardware.
So, better hardware um leads to better
num more flops, and also depends on the
data type. Um which means that if you
look at the the spec sheet, um different
uh data types will have different flops.
If you try to do float 32, nowadays it's
going to be really really slow because
um they're not really optimizing for
that workload, whereas uh now BF16 or um
FP8 are going to be much uh faster.
Okay? And MFU, now you know what MFU is.
It's uh the you know, actual flops
divided by promised flops.
All right. So, to go back to the
question of why is MFU 0.5?
And to understand that, I'm going to
have to introduce this idea of
arithmetic intensity.
And and the re- reason is that, well,
it's not just um
you know, doing a bunch of
matmuls and then you're done and looking
at how long it the matmuls take.
Um this is my very
uh cartoon version of what uh hardware
looks like.
Um you have high bandwidth memory
uh and then you have where the the
compute uh cores or the cell
accelerators chips are.
And then um what how do you compute?
Well, you have to
send your inputs, your matrices there's
there's uh tensors are sitting down
here, from the memory to the
accelerator. You do the the computation,
and then you uh send it back.
Okay? So, if you want to measure how
long this takes, this sort of depends on
two things. One is the accelerator
speed,
which is what we've talked about uh just
you know, just now.
But the other thing that matters is the
memory bandwidth of your hardware, which
we haven't talked about.
And uh if you look at the spec sheet, we
talked about how the flops per second
was
um
1979 E12
/ 2.
And the bytes per second, which is the
memory bandwidth, this is 3.3 uh
terabytes per per second.
Okay? And remember we uh why we were
looking at memory
um
uh
how much things took to store,
it's going to it's
most obviously that, well, you just if
you have a model that's too big it
doesn't fit in your memory, that's not
going to be fun. But also, it turns out
that memory you need to move this
memory, which takes time. So, actually
the size of how large things actually
influences uh speed as well.
Okay, so um I'm going to talk through
some operations, and I'm going to
basically compute how long things are
going to take, and introduce this idea
of arithmetic intensity.
Okay, so suppose I have a million uh
dimensional uh vector of BF uh 16,
and um and I'm going to just compute a
value
on this. So, re- remember ReLU is just
uh max of X and zero uh done
element-wise on the entire vector here.
So, um
I count two things. One is the number of
bytes that were moved.
So, um I have to read X,
um in you know, copy it into the the um
the accelerators,
and each of this is going to be two
because a BF16 is two bytes per float
times N floats. So, that's two N, and
then I'm going to write Y back. So,
that's another two N.
Okay? So, that's the number of bytes
that have to be uh moved. And then, how
many flops were done?
Well, um each of these elements, I'm
just comparing with zero, and that's it.
So, that's N comparisons.
Um
Okay?
So, now I look at the communication
time, which is the number of bytes
that were I needed to move,
um you know, divided by the the speed of
that movement,
and that gives me the time, which is,
you know, 1e-6
uh you know, seconds.
And what about the computation time?
That's the flops divided by flops per
second.
So, that's um 1e-9.
Okay.
So, there's also going to be another
important uh assumption, which generally
we try to hold is that we overlap
communication and computation. We're
going to talk more about that when we
talk more deeply about GPUs, but the
idea is that in in this case, as as we
don't sit here waiting for the the you
know, the things to move, as soon as
they're there, we start computing them,
and then
um we move them back. So, that this this
movement and also the compute is
happening at the same time.
So, mathematically uh
we're just going to assume that the
total time is the max of the two,
because we're going to assume that we
can perfectly overlap them. In practice,
it's not going to be perfectly
overlapped, there's going to be some
overhead, but this is uh um a good
enough for now.
Okay, so the total time,
as we see here, is 1e-6.
Okay.
So, if you ask, you know, what is the
bottleneck here?
So, when the communication time is
greater than the computation time, then
we call it uh the algorithm memory
bound,
because you're spending most of your
time just waiting for bits to show up.
And when the com- computation time is
greater than communication time, that's
compute bound,
because then you're actually, you know,
your bottleneck is actually doing the
compute.
And so, in this case, uh what is ReLU?
Rectified linear units. Oh, sorry. Is it
memory bound or uh you know,
compute bound? Memory bound.
>> [laughter]
>> A memory bound. Yeah.
Um So, and it it's clear, right?
Because, you know, the compute is way
less than the communication.
Okay.
So,
here's another way to see it, and this
is where I'm going to define the
intensity. So, what is intensity of an
accelerator is essentially how much work
can the accelerator do
do per byte transferred?
And for any given accelerator based on
the spec sheet, you basically have um
the the flops per second divided by the
um the bytes per second.
Okay? So, how much useful uh work can
you do per byte that's moved? For H100s,
that's uh 295.
Okay? So, that means for every byte
of
um you can do 295
um floating point operations.
Okay? So, that's an intuitive number to
uh kind of have in your head, about 300.
Um okay, so now the arithmetic intensity
of uh algorithm is how much actual work
was done per byte for this workload.
And if you look at it for the ReLU
computation, it's flops over bytes,
and it's uh actually it's so this is
actually a
a quarter, I guess. Um
not half. So, the point is that it's
very small,
um 0.25.
Okay, so now we can talk about
bottlenecks through the language of
intensity. So, if something is memory
bound if the arithmetic intensity is
smaller than uh the accelerator
intensity, and compute bound if it's
greater than accelerator intensity.
All right, so these are equivalent, and
if you look at the algebra, it's
basically you have two fractions, and
then you just kind of multiply and
divide to you basically switch the terms
around.
Okay, so in this case,
um
you know, we're uh memory bound.
So, in general, we're going to find
ourselves in a situation where we're
memory bound because data movement is
expensive, and so if you can get higher
arithmetic intensity, that's good.
Okay.
So, 0.25. If you see that number, if
someone tells you your arithmetic
intensity is 0.25, you should uh say,
"Oh, this is this is really bad."
Yeah. What's some typical arithmetic
intensity for
Yeah, so we'll get to that. Okay.
All right. So, so okay, so one way to
think about increasing arithmetic
intensity is that let's just try to do
more stuff uh per unit of byte moved.
Okay, so the GELU is another activation.
Um it kind of looks like this. It's
some, you know, formula that is uh more
uh um
um doesn't
uh you know, have zeros.
Um
and uh if you do this calculation, the
number of bytes are moved back and
forth, it's still 2N + 2N.
Um
and the flops
here, it's about 20 um flops per
element-wise GELU operation. So, it's
20N. Right? So, the arithmetic intensity
is, let's say, five. This is a kind of a
crude estimate. And in this case, are we
memory bound or compute bound?
Memory bound. Memory bound.
Right? Because five is still smaller
than 295.
Way smaller.
So, even though GELU does a lot of uh a
lot of work,
um more work than ReLU, in the way that
things are structured, it's still um
it's still memory bound.
Which means that if you were just
computing ReLU and GELU, you think
that, well, GELU is like so complicated,
it must be really expensive, but
actually it's exactly the same. Right?
Because that's not where the bottleneck
is.
Okay, so now let's uh look at some uh
linear operations. So, dot product.
Okay, so dot product, you have a vector
X, you have a vector W, size N, and you
take the dot product. So, how many bytes
are moved? So, you read X, which is 2N,
read W, which is 2N, and then you write
Y, which is a scalar, which is two.
Okay, and the number of flops is you do
the N multiplications and
uh and
N minus one additions, so that's 2N
minus one.
Okay, so um what's the arithmetic
intensity? Oh, for this one it's uh
about half.
Okay, so which is also pretty bad, which
means that hopefully by you get the
idea, it's memory bound.
Okay?
So, what about a matrix vector product?
Okay, so what I have this um X is a
vector, W is a M by M matrix, um and you
perform this product.
Um how many of you think this will be
compute bound?
How many of you think memory bound?
Okay.
So, let's see.
So, I'm going to read X, uh read, which
is 2N, read W, which is 2N squared, and
write Y, which is uh 2N. And there's uh
the number of flops is basically you're
you know uh doing N dot products, so
that's N times the cost of doing a dot
product.
And uh the arithmetic intensity is, you
know, barely barely higher.
Um
So,
uh so this is,
you know, um
also memory bound.
Okay.
So, now let's talk about matrix
multiplication. So, this is where things
get um interesting. So, I have a M by M
matrix, another M by M matrix, and I
multiply them.
And uh the number of bytes that were
moved was um
you know, 2N squared plus 2N squared,
and then I have to write a 2N squared um
bytes uh back to Y.
And the number of flops here is N
squared dot products.
And then what's arithmetic intensity?
It's 300, woohoo. Okay, so 340, and in
general it's roughly N over three.
Um and intuitively this makes sense
because you're sending N squared things,
but you're computing N cubed things.
Right? So, the number of things you're
computing over number of things you're
sending is order N.
And this gets better the larger you make
the matrices.
So, and in general,
this is why when you hear people talk
about, "Oh, we need to make large batch
sizes or have large matrices." It's
exactly this. If you if you're under uh
the accelerator intensity,
um
making things smaller doesn't actually
speed things up, right? It's all kind of
the same. Whereas, if you get to the
point where you're over uh this, then
you're actually saturating your um you
know,
uh GPUs.
Okay, so finally this is uh you know,
compute bound.
Okay.
So, as long we have large matrices,
we're actually pretty good. We're in uh
compute bound, saturating the
accelerator. And the question about
earlier about, you know, what about
transformers? Well, it turns out we'll
see um
in both your assignment, but also in the
next lecture, that transformers are
essentially big, you know, matrix
multiplications with some things
sprinkled in between. So, um
the so that's good news from arithmetic
intensity, and this is by design.
Transformers are designed in a certain
way to have high um arithmetic uh
intensity.
And one comment here, just to foreshadow
the inference lecture, is that matrix
vector products is essentially kind of
what goes on when you're doing
transformer inference. Right? Because
inference, you're generating one token
at a time,
and so you only get to it's like a
vector that you're trying to dot product
with a with a matrix.
Um and that's and that's where as we saw
was uh memory bound.
Whereas in training time, you get this
whole sequence, and you're processing
all at once.
Okay.
So, um note also that the intensity
depends on the the precision. So, by
default everything we're doing here is
FP uh you know, 16.
Um
Okay, so also the to tie it to the other
question about MFU, and the reason you
might be getting
um low MFU is that while you
um might be doing
>> [clears throat]
>> um so, MFU is a a promised flops uh
sorry, actual
over promised. Right? So, if you have
really large memory band uh bottlenecks,
then you're not actually going to get
very good you know, throughput even
though um
you know, you
you know, the the promise is like if you
didn't have memory bottlenecks, you were
just like going through and doing all
the computations of your model.
Okay, uh final thing on arithmetic
intensity, um
roofline plots.
So, there's a nice way to Yeah?
Yeah.
Generally speaking, these models tend to
be memory bound, as they say, for most
of the computation.
But yet, the accelerators are 50% is not
as good, and then maybe you get 70,
maybe you get 80, that's really good.
Mea- meaning that the accelerator is
outsized compared to memory. Uh
bandwidth.
Um why is it like that? Why do these
accelerators
big just big Well, they're just idling
or waiting for memory.
So, so um the question is uh could you
design maybe accelerators that had
better um you know, characteristics?
Um yeah, maybe when we talk about GPUs
and understand a bit more how they work,
we can talk about uh why this is.
Um but if you have uh an answer, you
should tell Jensen, and maybe he can um
design a better um better hardware.
>> [snorts]
>> Um
okay, so
let's visualize the relationship between
arithmetic intensity and performance.
So, this plot basically plots the
arithmetic intensity on the X axis. So,
every
um vertical uh slice here is corresponds
to a particular, let's say, algorithm.
And then we have these lines here, and
each of these lines corresponds to,
let's say, a particular accelerator.
Maybe
um you know, H100s or
uh B200s or so.
And so, uh what this shows is and then
on the Y axis is um the flops per second
that are realized.
So, if your algorithm has low arithmetic
intensity, like um value or dot
products, you're going to be over here,
which means that the flops per second
realized is going to be um
you know, not as high as your peak
accelerator.
And as you increase the memory
uh arithmetic intensity, that's going to
things are going to be better. You're
going to be able to saturate your um
your hardware up until a certain point.
And after a certain point, you're
compute bound, and uh you're
obviously you can't exceed the peak
flops um
Okay?
All right, so
um let's go on here. Okay.
So, um now I'm going to go back and talk
about memory and compute for
um the operations that we need in um in
training.
Right? So, so far we've done tensor
operations, basically matmuls, and um
you know, we saw basically how much
memory it took and how much compute it
took.
Um and the interaction between them.
So, now let's actually think about what
it takes to train. So, here is uh our
running example here. Um actually it's
not a linear network, uh just a deep
network. Um
so, I'm going to consider a case where I
have um a input, which is a B by D uh
input. Um and a number of layers, where
each layer is a D by D uh matmul.
Um pa- and then that produces some
um set of pre-activations, and then
element-wise value, that produces some
activations of the first layer, and then
this is repeated again and again.
Okay, and the output is just going to be
the same size.
Okay, so the deep network um I mean,
just to see what it looks like in
PyTorch, um just so it's basically a set
of blocks.
Each block uh
is
has a weight vector associ- uh sorry, a
weight matrix associated with it.
Okay?
And um
So, when you the number of parameters
here is D squared times the number of
layers, L.
And when you run the the model on a
batch of data,
um what we're doing is we're going
through the layers, and each layer um
we basically apply the linear
transformation, and then a point-wise uh
value activation.
Um and then we do that for all the
layers. Okay? So, this is hopefully
straightforward.
Um
very simple model.
>> [clears throat]
>> Um okay, so now let's talk about, you
know, uh
you know, gradients.
So, in uh let's use an actually a sim-
even simpler example. So, this is just
um a simple linear model regression.
Um
so, we have a a vector 1 2 3, a weight
uh a vec- weight vector um 1 1 1.
Um
and we take a dot product uh and we form
this uh MSE loss.
Okay? And what happens when we uh you
know, take the the do the backward pass
um
is that
um each of the the variables involved in
this computation graph has a gradient
that is um either set or not set. So,
um
the
w.grad gets set to, you know, 1 2 3.
Okay?
So, this is just basic uh mechanics of
uh you know, PyTorch. I think it should
be familiar to um all of you.
So now, the question is like how much uh
compute does
uh gradients you know, take?
Okay. So, let's count flops for
computing gradients.
>> [clears throat]
>> So, let's take a you know, simplified
model
um where you have um an X which is BID
and um times a W1 matrix.
Um well, we're going to it's sort of
ignore this uh value for now uh just for
simplicity times W2 which is the same D
by D may same sa- shape D by D matrix.
Okay, I'm going to use einsum here um
uh for reasons that will become clear.
Um so, the first thing you do in this
linear network as you take X and you
take W1. X is batch by input dimension.
Uh W1 uh is in by out and you get a
batch by out.
Okay? And H2 takes H1 and W2 and it's
this kind of the same story. These are
just matmuls.
So, and then you form a loss. I'm just
setting it to some arbitrary just to get
a number out.
Okay.
So, what happens in the in the backward
pass? Um
I'm going to call these retain gradients
for debugging purposes which you'll see
later. Uh you take the backward pass on
the loss and the question is how much
work did that uh how many floating point
operations was that?
Okay, so let's zoom in on one layer.
Let's focus on the second layer here.
So, this this uh layer.
Um
and so, the second layer takes H1 and
just multiplies by a matrix W2 to get
H2. And that's it.
So, if you look at the num- uh the flops
in the forward pass, this is just uh a
matmul.
And we just uh take the three dimensions
and we multiply them together and BF16
that's uh two bytes. Uh sorry, that's
that's irrelevant. It's um this is just
two because it's a addition and a
multiplication.
Okay.
Um
so, in the backward pass, you know, what
does this look like? Okay, so in the
backward pass, um if you remember your
chain rule and your backprop algorithm,
you have to compute two things. You have
to compute um
the the kind of backward message the the
gradient of the loss with respect to
your your kind of input
um
and you also have to compute the
gradient with respect to your
parameters.
Okay? And what do those gradients look
like? Um this is just by
you know, the definition of uh these um
I guess it's just the chain rule here
um written in einsum notation. You take
the
the D loss D H2 which is H2.grad.
That's a a batch by out uh you know,
matrix.
And you multiply it by um W2
which is in by out.
And
and then um
that gives you uh
H1.grad which is D loss uh D H1.
And and which is batch in.
Okay? So, I always uh get this uh you
know, confused whenever you see if you
see, you know, learn calculus there's
like, you know, one of them has a
transpose and like I always forget which
order to put them in. And einsum I think
makes it very clear because if you we
you can remember even just like looking
at the scalar case that it has to look
like H1.grad is H2.grad times W2 and the
only question is, you know, what uh how
do you index things? And you index
things by basically looking at the shape
of these uh in the named dimensions. And
in this case, it's just a matrix
multiplication where you are summing
over the output, you know, dimension.
Okay? And when you do that, we can check
that so H1.grad was the thing that was
computed by loss.backward and this is
actually indeed the same thing that I
kind of wrote out here just as a sanity
check.
Okay, so the other thing you have to
compute is
uh
W the gradient with respect to the
parameters. And that's uh
D loss D H2 times H1.
So, it's the same kind of backward
message that's coming back but
multiplying with other thing that you're
not taking the
you know, the gradient you know, with
respect to.
And you just write out the the
dimensions and in this case, you're
summing over um the the batch dimension.
Okay.
So,
but the you know, the nice thing is that
if you just look at this, we know how
expensive uh you know, this is. The
number of flops is essentially the
product of all the dimensions. It
doesn't matter which ones you're you're
batching or not. It's it's basically you
enumerate over the IJK and you you
aggregate the way you aggregate is
different but um
the the flops is the you know, the same.
Okay, so notice that the backward pass
is exactly twice as expensive as the
forward pass and this is because you
have to take you know, compute two
uh gradients. One with respect to the
parameters the for each parameter and
then one with respect to the input the
other thing that's not the parameter.
Okay?
Maybe I'll pause any questions about
that.
>> [clears throat]
>> Okay, so now that was just for W2.
And you just need to apply this to all
the parameters in network and if you put
it all together,
you will see that for this network,
the forward pass is two times
the number of data points which is B
times the number of parameters flops.
And the backward pass is twice of that
which is four times the number of data
points times number of parameters flops.
And so, the grand total is 2 + 4 is 6
and uh 6 times number of data points and
parameters. So, this is where the 6 uh
ND uh comes from that you might have
seen in various places. It's just like
uh counting forward and you know,
backward.
So, we did this for just these uh deep
networks. Um but it turns out that this
is actually a good approximation for uh
transformers as well as soon as long as
the uh context length isn't too large.
If the context length is too large then
you get the context length squared and
that's
uh more flops that isn't in this kind of
accounting.
Okay, so uh let's talk a bit about So,
now we have gradients.
Now we have to the other piece when you
do training is we have to do
optimization.
So, uh like here's our deep network. Um
I'm going to just so that we're I'm not
just giving you uh what's in the
assignment one, I'm going to use um the
Adagrad optimizer which is um uh from
this is from 2011. This is predates
Adam. It's where you can think about it
somewhere in between SGD and um Adam.
And uh basically it's SGD where you um
you know, look at the the you know, the
second moments of the gradient.
Um momentum is where you look at the
first moment of gradients and um Adam is
where you, you know, uh combine the the
two of them. Um I'm not going to have
time to go into the optimizer details
here since we're focusing mostly on the
uh the usage.
So, we can define an um
you know, optimizer.
And
and when you compute the the you know,
the gradients, um
uh
and you compute gradients and then when
you take an optimizer step, um
if you're defining your new optimizer,
so in the assignment one, you're going
to uh uh implement Adam.
Um for each of the parameter uh
you know, groups which are, you know, in
this case W1 or W2,
um
we look at there's something called the
optimizer state which is uh of you know,
storage that you can the optimizer uses
while it's it's it's running.
Um and what we're computing in Adagrad
is uh something is the squared
gradients. Um the sum of the squared of
gradients.
Um so,
here we're getting it from the optimizer
state. We're updating it with the
current gradient and we're storing it
back.
And then after you update the the G2,
then you update the parameters.
>> [clears throat]
>> Okay? So, in Adagrad it's you basically
divide by the square root of the
gradient you know, average gradient
squared or sum of gradient squared
rather.
Okay, so um
let's see. So, I'm actually going to uh
maybe skip the
you know, the training
loop. Actually,
wait.
Hold on.
I think I actually skipped something I
didn't mean to.
Okay, so that was uh the optimizer
state. And now let's look at how much
memory the optimizer is using or in
general what is the memory usage. So,
for parameters in this network, there's
D squared parameters
for each of the L layers, and each
parameter takes two bytes if we're
storing an FP16, so that's number of
parameters.
Activations,
um
this is
uh you know
two times
um the
which is for BF16
you know, batch times D times the number
of layers for every layer you have an
activation. You have gradients,
uh which is basically a copy of all the
you know, the parameters. And this is
all the BF16, and the optimizer state is
for every
actually this should be the
I think this should be sorry, not this
I'll fix this as a typo. This should be
the number of parameters, not parameter
memory.
Um
and this should be number of parameters.
So, number of parameters
uh times two, and then this is four
times the number of parameters.
And the reason for this is that it's
customary to use FP32 for the optimizer
states for stability reasons. Um
obviously people have tried using uh
BF16, and what tends up happening is
that now you're taking squares and
you're averaging all those steps, and it
doesn't uh you know, it's not very
stable.
Um
and
for AdaGrad it's here we have four bytes
per parameter for storing the optimizer
state. Adam, you store the first order
bit
uh and the second order moments, so
that's eight bytes.
So, if you think about the optimizer
state is actually a lot of the memory um
uh
you know, used.
Um one note is that
you know, remember memory serves kind of
two purposes. One is like how much you
have to store this thing in your HBM.
But the other thing is that it has to be
shipped to the um
uh to
the [clears throat] um
to to the accelerators, and in general
um the optimizer state is not really the
bottleneck for for compute. So, the
amount of memory here is not really uh
so important for um you know,
performance in terms of speed, but it is
uh means that you can't fit large models
in your your memory.
>> [clears throat]
>> Okay. So, to put it um you know,
together
uh as we mentioned, the number of
parameters here is D times D times L,
and the number of flops is D times
um number of tokens or number of data
points times number of parameters.
So, for transformers, this is going to
be uh a bit more complicated, but you're
going to do that in assignment one, and
you do it more um carefully.
Okay, I'm going to skip the training
loop. This is just a sort of a general
um
kind of review.
Two things I want to quickly touch on
before we conclude. One is that
as we see, memory does uh
have an important effect both on the
ability to store large models, but also
sometimes um your speed. And so, in
general you want to reduce your memory
usage. So, there's two
um things that people you know,
typically do. One is uh gradient
accumulation.
Um so, in general you want to use batch
sizes that are large enough uh to
improve stability up to a a critical
batch size which Tatsu will talk about
later.
Um
and as we saw that activation memory
scales with batch size. So, you might
going to run out of memory at some point
if you have too large batch sizes. So,
gradient accumulation says, well
you compute, you have these micro
batches, and you compute the gradient on
the micro batches, and then you just
accumulate the gradients. You don't zero
out the gradients, and every
um batch size over micro batch size
steps, you update the parameters and a
zero out the gradients.
Okay? So, this is actually a very simple
code change um which allows you to save
um you know, on compute.
So, the other thing I'll quickly mention
is activation checkpointing. So, in
training
we need to
uh uh
store
in general the activations of all the
layers. This is done by you know,
default.
Um actually interestingly for inference,
we don't need to compute uh the
gradients, so we only need to store the
current layers activations.
Um but for training
the memory usage is
um
um B times D times um
two [clears throat] times L.
And
um the question is can you reduce this?
So, the activation checkpointing also
known as gradient checkpointing or
rematerialization. The key idea here is
that um in the forward pass, you just
keep the activations for only a subset
of the layers.
And in the backward pass, you recompute
the missing activations from the last
checkpoint. That's why it's called
checkpointing. And this is a general
trick that you see in you know, systems
which is trading off if you want to
reduce memory, you can just recompute
things.
Um so, here we're going to define this
uh to operationalize this. This is
actually fairly
um
you know,
uh
easy actually. I didn't
Okay, maybe I didn't see the Okay, so
basically what you do here is you have
the same model except for
um
you just add torch.utils.checkpoint
on a layer.
So, that means do this computation, but
don't store any of the intermediate um
um
you know, activations. Only store what
is uh needed. So, this means that um
if you store all the activations,
remember in your deep network, you have
the thing that's pre the ReLU, and the
thing that's after the ReLU.
Right? So, that's a lot of of storage,
and instead if you do activation
checkpointing on those blocks where each
block has a linear and a ReLU, you don't
store the pre ReLU, and you save
basically half. Uh you can get away with
half the memory.
And then at the when you're doing the
backward pass, um
you need G3, but you can compute G3
easily from H2.
Okay, you can go farther than this.
Um you can say
well, I can store all the layers, but
you know, in extreme case, I can just
store no layers.
Um and so, that will be memory
maximally memory efficient. The only
thing is that the compute is going to be
L squared because every for every one of
these layers you have to start from the
beginning.
Um and maybe a sweet spot is if you
store the checkpoints at square root L
layers, that means your activation
memory is square root of L, and your
your com recomputation overhead is also
um you know, uh square root of L. So,
that's uh that's balanced.
Okay, so um to summarize this lecture
um everything is operating on on
tensors, parameters, gradients,
activations, optimizer states, data.
Um we introduce this Einops, which
hopefully you guys can embrace as a way
to think about tensor operations.
Um six times number of data points times
number of parameters is a formula which
now we have demystified as number of
flops per
um
for training step.
And uh
actually if this is training step, this
should be batch size. Um
and then we talked about arithmetic
intensity and roofline analysis, which
allows us to diagnose whether a
computation is memory bound or uh
compute bound. Um matrix multiplications
are compute bound. Basically everything
else is memory bound.
Um and then finally, gradient
accumulation activation checkpointing
are ways to reduce the memory
and by reducing the memory, uh that
allows you to use um bigger uh batch
sizes.
Okay, so that's it for today's lecture.
So, next week uh Tatsu will talk about
architectures.